I want someone to watch this movie do
not know anything about the room and
think wow that actor like really pulled
off that part like that I didn't want
them to walk out of there thinking in
any way that this guy is not a good
actor or that he's has anything
affiliated with being in the worst movie
or anything like that I really wanted
him to be this unique eccentric
genuinely mysterious character Greg
Sestero and Tommy Wiseau's friendship
could probably be indicted into the
Friendship Hall of Fame at this point
the story of their unlikely relationship
and the creation of greatest bad movie
called classic the room has been the
focus of Greg's New York Times
best-selling book the disaster artist
and an award-winning film adaptation
directed by James Franco but the new
movies best friends Volume one and two
written by Greg explores this
relationship in a unique and fascinating
way the film has Greg and Tommy playing
characters on screen that are loosely
based on themselves acting out a story
that was inspired by their friendship
and a particular road trip they went on
together i sat down with Greg to talk
about the unique nature of making films
that are a mix of fiction and reality
from his own life and working with Tommy
again thank you to movie for sponsoring
this video and of course you play more
but you want me to play mark a nice big
role come on I need your help I need a
hand the first draft of the disaster
house is like 600 pages so there's a lot
of moments a lot of craziness that had
happened that didn't get told in my
video about Franco's adaptation of
Greg's book I expressed some of my
frustration with its avoidance of some
of the darker stranger elements of the
story best friends slash fiends as you
can tell by the title embraces
wholeheartedly the strangeness and the
tension of the real relationship not too
close okay it may bite you
looking all my stuff yes sorry a little
bit nosy guy yeah to me the films feel
partially like a response to the
disaster artist movie like the untold
half of the story I mean I was in that
mindset when I was writing the script
cuz I had just seen the disaster artist
movie but I mean really this story was
inspired by that road trip so it was in
a different time in our friendship
the mysterious not fully trusting either
person because they don't really know
what each other is about I think that
was kind of the driving force which is
very much true during that time I mean
at the time of the road trip you know I
didn't know where Tommy was from I
didn't really know anything Tommy where
were you from oh no like like originally
[Music]
where are you from
still after being friends for five years
and making the movie together that was
it it was all still very mysterious I'm
the liar you know I had heard theories
from other people that I'd known that
knew him you know he could be really
kind at times and really kind of
off-putting at time so it's like you
really like him but then it's like he's
controlling this is amber who I was
telling you about
I don't know okay I don't have time for
this very busy right now to change
really quickly go the way she say
independent girl huh she's still
condescending can you see that she's too
negative John so there was a lot of
experiences there and I've noticed I've
gone through a lot of really weird stuff
and there's nothing better than to pull
from your own life because you you see
these people and they're real instead of
making up a scene that's got you know no
depth you're able to really pull from
something you've gone through John I
don't know where you dug this guy yep
let's just make sure this is profitable
for you and I okay hey dude I'm here
it's clear that elements of the market
Johnny characters in the room were
inspired by Tommy's view of certain
aspects of his relationship with Gregg
like Tommy feeling betrayed by Gregg but
the room and Tommy don't formally
acknowledge this best friends does
something similar but in a more explicit
way many aspects of the true story are
represented in best friend
[Music]
what happened to your beer you don't
have a shave it look better
Wow hey guys you like it yeah great and
many scenes seem to comment on aspects
of their friendship like the way Tommy
construes his past the hell did we get
210 ounces of gold taping hard work when
life gives you lemons like the room make
lemonade this scene seems to be a
commentary about people in Greg's life
finding out about the room and the
embarrassment that may have caused him
at some point yeah I can explain this
scene seems to portray Greg revealing
the book to Tommy you can't write it now
it will explain and Tommy's reaction why
do you do
I found something alright it's a legit
industry this thing it can help us and
Volume one culminates with a scene where
these two friends get to really embody
and act out some of the real tension
they experienced in their relationship
at one point we were shooting that cliff
scene it was almost getting to play out
like this fake moment that he thought
was gonna happen that's lived in our
minds for all these years and then we're
like actually they're doing it acting
out the scene that was in his mind for
so long and wondering like what would
have happened if you know and so that
was really exciting in a lot of ways and
therapeutic because you're like getting
out these like weird thought you've had
and and I think for him as well I
remember we were shooting that scene
like he was really on like he didn't
forget any lines he was really focused
there was like a different feel to him
so I wonder if he was just thinking
about that day or really believing that
that was gonna happen
volume 2 thematically takes a turn and
seems to be about Greg moving past his
association with the room and on to
other creative endeavors while in a way
beginning to do that itself the humor
Tommy brings to the screen and best
friends is similar to what you see in
the room but there's a shift in context
when I wrote the disaster artist I could
see Tommy so clearly like he came to
life in a way that I could kind of
control you know because if you try to
get him to say something or act a
certain way he may not do it on the spot
or he may not be able to convey what he
once did organically and so with the
disaster I was able to write this
character that I experienced in a way
that you could feel everything that he
has to offer the craziness the part
where he's charming and weird and so now
I write this kind of deep character for
Tommy that you know compared to what
he's used to playing now can he deliver
these monologues and convey the story
that needs to be told that was the other
challenge
maybe you should be me for one day when
he went off script it's still kind of
work
because he's still being himself so you
know the memorization wasn't as much of
a problem it helps you see where Tommy
has real talent illustrating how his
acting is more than just so bad it's
good he still gets laughs but he's
playing a guy that was believable
dressing that way looking that way we're
shooting these scenes I have to hold
back from laughing at his reactions to
things and that's what the audience does
and you're interested to see what he
does next he doesn't see life the same
way anybody else does he just doesn't
care he just he just is and so I think
it supersedes good or bad I think it's
its own kind of thing and it shines a
light on what it was that drew Gregg to
Tommy in that acting class where they
met in the acting class like you know
you watch a performance there's a lot of
good performances but something about
the way that he goes up and attacks a
scene or thinks something is great
because you do it this way it's it's
unpredictable and I think that's what
makes it fun it's almost infectious and
genuine in a way that like you can't
help yeah yeah there's days where things
he finds funny and the way he decides to
jump out in a certain way I always most
of the time I find it really funny you
say most of the time I think a lot of
people would come away from an
experience like the room or look at that
from the outside and maybe assume you
wouldn't want to return to that it was
their hesitancy about kind of jumping
back into working with him on a creative
project yeah that's why I took 15 years
and it took they took enough time to
where I was comfortable with myself to
take on a project to then put him in and
take on that challenge so I wasn't
really being directed by him
or he wasn't running the project it was
a chance for me okay from the beginning
I saw something unique in you now let me
try to show this audience what I think
you can do so what do you want to be
what do you wanna be let me try to
capture this a lot like he did with the
room that no one else saw as being great
you know he thought it was great and
obviously people responded to it thanks
to movie for sponsoring this video movie
is a hand curated cinema streaming and
download service Mubi selects and
presents 30 for you to watch at a time
every single day they add a new one and
take one away and human chooses each
film they have called classics
award-winning masterpieces forgotten
gems festival favorites and hard-to-find
stuff that you won't find anywhere else
I end up enjoying everything I watch on
there and a lot of it I've never heard
of or wouldn't have watched if it wasn't
for Moby there are no ads on the
platform it's available globally and you
can try it for free for a whole month
when you go to movie comm slash Thomas
flight that's M ubi dot-com slash Thomas
flight for your extended free trial
thanks again to Mubi for sponsoring this
video special thank you to my patrons
you can get access to a special podcast
I do stickers and extra bonus videos by
going to patreon.com slash Thomas play
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
again next time
you